i
[Música]
hola bienvenidos al debate de france 24
soy santiago lópez gonzález xiomara
castró se convirtió en la primera mujer
en llegar a la presidencia de honduras
ella misma lo destacó en su primer
discurso a la nación en el que resaltó
el rompimiento de las tradiciones es que
por primera vez en 200 años de república
independiente una mujer toma las riendas
de este país centroamericano con enormes
enormes retos por delante quién es
xiomara castró la nueva presidenta de
honduras solo contamos en el siguiente
informe
xiomara castró era una primera dama más
pero el golpe de estado de militares y
empresarios hondureños en 2009 contra su
marido y presidente manuel zelaya la
llevaron a un primer plano
viene de obediencia en gobierno
en su tercer intento de lograr la
presidencia se ha alejado de su marido y
ha utilizado como una de sus bazas de
campaña ser la primera mujer presidenta
en la historia de honduras un país
tradicionalmente machista y conservador
[Música]
[Aplausos]
en este sentido prometió aprobar el
aborto en tres causales y ampliar
derechos para el colectivo lgtb
como el matrimonio igualitario
además promete un cambio político
después de 12 años de gobiernos
conservadores salpicados por casos de
corrupción y lazos con el narcotráfico
su promesa de construir un estado
socialista y democrático ha generado
virulentas críticas de la oposición que
vaticinan que honduras va a ser una
nueva cuba o venezuela
temores en un país que igual que el
resto de la región sufre de poca cultura
política y suelen aflorar autoritarismos
personalistas por lo que un fracaso en
el reformismo podría acabar con las
esperanzas de su promesa de una honduras
libre soberana e independiente
como lo decíamos los retos son múltiples
honduras afronta una profunda crisis
económica pobreza migración corrupción y
en general falta de perspectivas de
futuro para sus habitantes según el más
reciente estudio realizado por el
instituto de estadística de ese país el
73 6 por ciento de los hondureños viven
en la pobreza así es la situación en la
que está este país veamos
honduras está a las puertas de una
transición política pero en un país
marcado por la corrupción el
narcotráfico y una pobreza que ronda el
70 por ciento la desconfianza en la
clase política es elevada pero siempre
se espera verdad que sea enjuiciado y
que no queden impunidad que todos estos
robos saqueos este actos de corrupción
sean castigados verdad como un
precedente para nuevas generaciones y
que puedan observar a nivel
internacional también que los hondureños
estamos haciendo las cosas
transparentemente honduras presentó el
primer golpe de estado del siglo 21 en
la región en 2009 militares sublevados
expulsaron del país al entonces
presidente manuel zelaya por su cercanía
ideológica con los gobiernos de
izquierda latinoamericanos he sido
secuestrado secuestrado a la fuerza con
violencia con brutalidad ese secuestro
es
sanz pasó al país de una bofetada al
mundo entero desde entonces la
democracia en el país ha estado en
entredicho con altos índices de
corrupción desde la llegada de juan
orlando hernández a la presidencia en
2014 se ha acusado al ejecutivo de lazos
con el narcotráfico
concretamente de politizar los órganos
de justicia y control reducir el alcance
de las investigaciones y aprobar leyes
para blanquear la corrupción algo que
hernández siempre ha negado
en cuentos
comunidad no tiene para ti
en 2015 una corte de nueva york inició
varios procesos políticos contra figuras
públicas y militares entre ellos el
hermano del ex presidente juan antonio
hernández finalmente condenado una
crisis política a la que se le sumó la
migratoria con caravanas promovidas por
la violación de los derechos humanos y
la falta de oportunidades en la nación
que enfrenta muchos retos
socioeconómicos un galopante descontento
social y altas cifras de violencia
pues así están las cosas en honduras que
comienza un nuevo capítulo político de
la mano de xiomara castró que prometió
la refundación de este país
centroamericano muy lejos de los vicios
políticos y que han regido allí a lo
largo de tantos años y que han mantenido
a este país en unas condiciones
difíciles vamos entonces a analizar este
tema con nuestras invitadas vamos a
verlo desde diferentes perspectivas
saludamos a suyapa figueroa presidenta
del colegio médico de honduras y
diputada electa por el partido salvador
de honduras de este país centroamericano
ya se encuentra en la ciudad de
tegucigalpa también hemos convocado a
este programa también se conecta desde
la capital hondureña johana bermúdez
ellas doctora en medicina interna y
dermatología y es diputada por el
partido nacional de honduras ustedes
nuestros televidentes también pueden
participar en el debate con sus
comentarios y preguntas lo pueden hacer
a través de nuestras redes sociales no
se encuentran en facebook en instagram y
en twitter estamos como france24 guión
bajo s arroba sant y luego que es bien
cuenta personal lesión recuerdo también
la etiqueta numeral el debate efe 24
esperamos todos sus comentarios y
preguntas sobre este tema entonces vamos
a comenzar el debate quiero conocer las
impresiones de los hechos sucedidos el
día de hoy en tegucigalpa en esa toma de
posesión allí en el estadio en la ciudad
de tegucigalpa ante la presencia de
varias delegaciones extranjeras varios
invitados de países vecinos de países
cercanos a honduras y de países aliados
como por ejemplo eeuu es valiosa la
participación a este evento de la
vicepresidenta de eeuu kamala harris
comienzo entonces con suyapa figueroa
allí en tegucigalpa suyapa gracias por
estar con nosotros en el programa y
mejor le digo diputada figueroa gracias
por acompañarnos y sus impresiones de
los hechos del día de hoy
muchísimas gracias bueno pues hoy el
pueblo hondureño y especialmente las
mujeres hemos vivido una verdadera
fiesta cívica una alegría una esperanza
que tenemos en un gobierno que he
surgido de la necesidad de combatir la
corrupción que ha sido uno de los más
grandes flagelos en los últimos 12 años
hemos tenido un gobierno dictatorial es
el gobierno que verdaderamente
han
y sean prácticamente
aliado con la corrupción y han promovido
leyes que lejos de buscar el perseguir
el delito
pues prácticamente blindan a estos
corruptos que tienen en una de las más
grandes crisis de pobreza en nuestro
país esa pobreza que ha obligado a
centenares a miles de hondureños de
compatriotas a abandonar nuestras
fronteras patrias y buscar mejores
derroteros que fuera de nuestro país sí
así que el pueblo de hoy hondureño hoy
ha vivido una fiesta estamos sumamente
complacidos con la alegría de tener
nuestra primera mujer presidenta a sus
200 años de historia con la mujer la
primera mujer presidenta de nuestro país
es un hecho relevante y es un hecho sin
duda para resaltar en la historia
política de este país centroamericano
dice mucho de el proceso que está
viviendo a nivel político le doy la
palabra ahora a la diputada bermúdez
para conocer su siempre como punto de
partida de este debate sobre los hechos
que tuvieron lugar hoy en tegucigalpa se
toma de posesión de xiomara castró como
primera presidenta de honduras
santiago primero agradecido con dios y
agradecido con frames 24 por darnos este
espacio de participación y sobre todo
para que también nuestra voz se escuche
porque al fin y al cabo la moneda
siempre tiene dos caras y es importante
escuchar la verdad quiero realmente
tener bien claro que es sumamente
importante hacer la cosa tiene
diferentes como mujer generamos
esperanza generamos euforia hoy tenemos
la primera
presidenta presidente mujer entonces
verá que ha sembrado en nuestras niñas
niños en nuestras mujeres sobre todo
aquella que venimos de la pobreza que la
educación nos ha llevado a donde hemos
llegado ha sembrado realmente esa
esperanza que cuando se hace las cosas
con disciplina con trabajo y sobre todo
buenos haces las cosas bien y
transparentes se puede llegar a ser la
presidenta de un país obviamente se está
enfrentando a grandes retos y desafíos
recuerden que estamos ante una terrible
pandemia que puso de rodillas los
sistemas de salud más de los países más
poderosos de nuestros países y además un
país centroamericano que fue el único
que fue azotado por dos terribles
huracanes destrozando gran parte nuestra
producción agrícola casa vivienda
carreteras etcétera que también son
retos que tendrá que enfrentar nuestra
ciudad presidenta pero estamos
convencidos que cuando la mueve
gobernamos generamos más certidumbre
para más confianza más tolerancia más
respeto y tratamos de trabajar en
coordinación hoy realmente estoy
bastante sorprendida porque he visto un
gabinete que creí que iba a tener un
rostro de mujer pero desafortunadamente
ojalá que no nos pasemos de que no
solamente que nos se queden en el
discurso de los hombres que van del
equipo que van a formar el gabinete solo
hay dos mujeres y es de alguna manera
también era un poco de la ejecución y el
resto las mujeres que recientemente
también apostaron por la anegación a la
presienta pero me falta mucho más para
hacerlo más importante es que honduras
está escribiendo hoy una nueva historia
con una mujer que tiene además de
experiencia política tienen algunas
expectativas diputado a ver mueve más
adelante vamos a comentar sobre sobre
ese gabinete de gobierno y de las
instituciones que harán parte de este
gobierno dirigido por xiomara castro
quiero remitirme ahora a ese discurso
que dio la mandataria a su primer
discurso ante los hondureños un discurso
en el que hizo fuertes críticas a los
gobiernos anteriores que estuvieron en
el poder en honduras los calificó de
dictaduras
hablo de las difíciles condiciones
económicas en las que está el país pero
no sé si a ustedes les pareció que faltó
también dar un poco de positivismo a los
hondureños sobre lo que va a suceder
sobre lo que viene sobre cómo va a ser
su gestión y se hablaron de promesas
pero no de muchos lineamientos de cómo
se van a llevar a cabo todas estas
proyecciones y planes que si en el
discurso suenan muy bien pero es a lo
que estamos acostumbrados en américa
latina' a que se diga en el público a
que se diga frente a los micrófonos pero
a la hora de realizar los hechos no lo
evidencian comienzo entonces con la
diputada figuraba para conocer sus
impresiones de este discurso
pero indudablemente es un discurso que
proviene desde lo más sentido de una
narco dictadura porque hay que remarcar
verdad que nos han metido en un tremendo
lío está narco dictadura que hemos
tenido y que obviamente ha estado
marcada por la corrupción nos dejaron
nos entregan un país prácticamente en
ruinas
recordemos que la pandemia no fue tan
grave como la corrupción la pandemia no
él no produjo tantos muertos como la
corrupción misma que generó este
gobierno y obviamente pues el
endeudamiento que tenemos ha sido enorme
los préstamos que se pidieron se puso la
cara de la pobreza y de la miseria de
nuestros centros asistenciales pero ese
dinero que se pidió prestado nos sirvió
para fortalecer nuestro sistema
sanitario entonces obviamente es un
discurso
tal vez usted sintió no esperanzador
pero nosotros los hondureños si tenemos
una gran esperanza tenemos una enorme
satisfacción de tener una una mujer que
viene del pueblo una mujer que ya tuvo
una excelente trayectoria como primera
dama de la nación y que obviamente la
mujer que asustó en carne propia
bueno tenemos problemas de conexión con
suyapa figueroa en la ciudad de
tegucigalpa mientras tanto continuamos
hablando con giovanna bermúdez también
hay en la capital hondureña sus
impresiones diputada bermúdez sobre este
discurso a usted también le dejó ese
sabor de boca de poco esperanzador poco
llamado a la unión muchas críticas al
gobierno anterior cuando lo que se está
esperando es que vislumbre cómo va a ser
el futuro el camino los retos que tienen
que afrontar los hondureños son muy
complicados y tal vez lo que se espera
es ver un poco cómo se van a empezar a
enfrentar
bueno
particularmente lo voy a decir que yo
realmente estaba esperando justo un
discurso que generara estamos un país
altamente por al polarizado y parte la
esperanza que muchos depositaron la
confianza en doña xiomara es que que por
ser una mujer que iba a enfrentar el
reto de estar frente al poder iba
obviamente tener como un discurso menos
masculino un discurso menos técnico anda
un disgusto más enfocado a generales
esperanza esa madre de familia a esa
madre soltera que está viendo cómo
solucionar los problemas reales de su
familia a esa juventud está queriendo no
emigrar del país a niza delincuencia de
cómo vamos a lograr controlar a esta a
ese sistema de salud que cómo vamos a
lograr fortalecer lesiones de en
realidad que iba a tener un discurso un
poco más esperanzador un poquito más
humano un poquito
cercano en realidad lo sentí un discurso
más dirigido a los que tenemos esta
formación académica altamente técnico
muy complejo lo cual probablemente no va
a ser digerido por el resto de la
población aunque sabemos que la
popularidad la euforia que se mostró en
el estadio pero realmente en el estadio
no esto no estaban los nueve miles de
hondureños que estábamos escuchando
esperanzado en el discurso que generaría
yo creo que es importante que la señora
presidenta sepa de mi piel su rol de
candidata y su rol de presidenta es
presidenta de todos los hondureños de
los 9 millones de hondureños que hayan o
no hayan votado por ellos nos guste o no
es la presidenta de todos durante creo
que es importante que ella se pueda ver
marcar un poco de su papel de candidata
y asumir un poco más una gallardía con
más valentía con más amor con más
compromiso con más conocimiento el papel
de ser la primera presidenta del amor yo
le voy a decir está si tenemos altísimas
expectativas tú actúa que a mujeres
líderes todos los colectivos que
apostaron por esa es ese paso de
participación real de la mujer después
de estar tanto tiempo luchando por la
igualdad de participación política claro
ahora es el momento de actuar como usted
dice ya la campaña determinó ya la banda
presidencial está sobre los hombros de
la presidenta y es el momento de
ejecutar todos esos planes diputada
figueroa sus impresiones de
de este discurso ya nos da usted unos
primeros lineamientos pero ella hablo
de convertir a honduras en un estado
socialista democrático
basado en la transparencia en la lucha
contra la corrupción en donde haya una
especie de refundación de este país cómo
se puede lograr ese cambio en un país
que tiene tantos problemas de base a
nivel social a nivel económico y como lo
decía la diputada bermúdez polarizado y
dividido políticamente que puede
entorpecer las marchas de algunos planes
en el congreso ya vemos la situación que
está viviendo el congreso hondureño en
este momento completamente dividido y
con dos líderes a la cabeza
bueno indudablemente estos grandes retos
que tiene el país como lo hemos dicho
anteriormente pasan por un gobierno
austero un gobierno transparente un
gobierno que combata la corrupción y que
no sea parte de ella como ha sido en
estos últimos 12 años de gobierno
y obviamente pues esto hará que aunque
tengamos escasos recursos estos recursos
y los hagamos producir el mayor
beneficio para la población creo que el
discurso de ella se basó más que todo en
este combate de la corrupción y si usted
se fijó en la respuesta del público lo
que más le entusiasmo fue justamente eso
que nosotros podamos no permitir que
estos actos que los llevaron a esa
tragedia que hemos tenido como país no
queden impunes y que refundemos el país
porque prácticamente el país lo tenemos
en ruinas
quebrantado el estado de derecho de un
gobierno ilegítimo entonces eso es lo
que queremos volver a la
institucionalidad y en la vida
democrática a nuestro país diputada
bermúdez repitiendo estas palabras un
estado socialista democrático estas
palabras en algunos sectores pueden caer
no también como se puede esperar dados
los antecedentes que hay en países como
nicaragua o venezuela países que han
hablado también de un discurso
socialista democrático y vemos el rumbo
que han tomado como sientan
estas bases de esta refundación de
honduras allí en la sociedad hondureña
donde hay una clase adinerada que
controla los sectores políticos y
productivos y controla en cierta forma
también el político en honduras y que
además tiene un cercano relacionamiento
con washington que su país lejos de ser
pues un país socialista entonces como se
pueden recibir esas palabras allí en
honduras mire creo que del dicho la
acción ahí realmente muchísimo trecho
ahora recordemos que honduras es un país
democrático que afortunadamente en las
recientes elecciones a pesar de que
tuvimos la mayor participación
masiva de hombres mujeres que fueron a
votar el mandato realmente el primer
puerto estado que el que determina
finalmente cómo se va a lograr la
independencia los poderes y está en el
congreso nacional y ahí ese mandato se
lo dio a seis partidos políticos que
desafortunadamente el partido de
gobierno en este momento aquí en el
pueblo les dio él poder de gobernar han
generado una crisis
nuestro nacional no sea partiendo
desechó y respetamos realmente el estado
de derecho al cual la campaña de ellos
fueron constante en eso va a ser difícil
que pase de un discurso a una acción
honduras es un país democrático donde el
voto representa la voz de cada hondureño
y hondureña que voy a votar que ha ido
vota aquí creo que más allá de gastar
fondos en pensar cómo vamos a hablar
nosotros en cambiar un poco la
representación política de este país
creo que lo más importante es que la
señora presidente insisto se demande un
poco de su papel de candidata y asuma su
rol como mujer una valentía que genere
certidumbre confianza para poderle dar
porque soluciones reales a los problemas
que está enfrentando no lo duras lo que
también te ángulo norte tenemos que ver
cómo generamos oportunidades de empleo
para nuestra niña de niño pero una cosa
es decirlo y otra cosas es cómo vamos a
generar oportunidades a nuestra niña
seño como mafo mentales turismo como una
fuente importante generación de empleo
cómo vamos a lograr que todo yo también
escuché que avivó no más violencia
contra las mujeres cómo vamos a lograr
que todas las mujeres que estamos en los
diferentes partidos políticos también
hacían violenta nuestro derecho entonces
sí creo yo que de la acción del dicho de
la acción va a ser difícil honduras es
un país que está su constitución
política es una contra es un país
democrático representada por tres
poderes independientes entre sí e ínter
coordinados entre sí
bueno dejo de lado el tema del discurso
y lo que mencionó la presidenta castró
en su primera intervención ante el
pueblo hondureño pasó a analizar otros
temas importantes porque los retos que
va a tener ya ustedes los han mencionado
a grandes rasgos son múltiples hay alta
pobreza la crisis económica
hay una falta de confianza en las
instituciones hasta cierto punto y
también hay muchos problemas de
seguridad allí problemas con las maras
problemas de narcotráfico
cuál es el problema que debe afrontarse
de manera inmediata que aqueje a
honduras que sea de inmediata acción por
parte de la presidenta diputada figueroa
que va a ser una prioridad
la prioridad ya se han establecido y la
lucha contra la corrupción el
restablecer el estado de derecho
recordemos que justamente está en
inestabilidad política que hemos tenido
la falta de independencia de los poderes
del estado el excesivo control por parte
de quien gobernaba pues ha alejado y ha
hecho que honduras no sea visto como un
país
pues para poder invertir esto alejado la
inversión ha generado pobreza y
obviamente la recuperación económica
pasa por afrontar todas estas
situaciones una vez que nosotros podamos
establecer esta independencia de los
poderes y poder volver a la credibilidad
y al estado de derecho pues
indudablemente la inversión va a venir y
la situación económica tan grave que
tiene el pueblo hondureño también se va
a mejorar claro y no insistimos en la
transparencia en el manejo y obviamente
en la participación de empresarios
recordemos que una a una parte
fundamental son los empresarios local y
los empresarios nuestros que le han dado
un rotundo respaldo a la candidatura y
ahora el gobierno de sumar a castró
claro estos son los que más fácilmente
pueden comenzar a generar empleo y eso
mejora las condiciones de vida y las
perspectivas de vida de los ciudadanos
su opinión rápidamente deportada
bermúdez para poder pasar a otros temas
la prioridad de la florida en la cima
la playa número uno es en este momento
no solamente para presentar
xiomara castró sino que más bien para
todo lo puedes del estado para todo lo
que de alguna manera cortamos haciendo
las cosas bien diferentes debe ser
buscar soluciones a la tasa alta tasa de
desempleo que en este momento tenemos
por lo tanto creo que es importante que
fortalezcamos nuevamente el tema de la
emprende emprendedurismo como una
herramienta importante para acercar
capital semi a las pequeñas familias y
haciendo pequeñas empresas más lograr
reducir organizar toda la carga
tributaria que hay para que los
inversionistas puedan venir y dar
oportunidades de empleo más allá de eso
también tenemos que garantizar asegurar
que tengamos seguridad jurídica y en la
seguridad nacional vean usted justo en
este momento ha habido una primera 30 en
uno de uno de los principios del de
atlántida entonces tenemos que también
garantizar la seguridad jurídica
seguridad territorial seguridad personal
y no solamente la seguridad comunitaria
porque también tenemos que mann
al más bajo índice la tasa de comisión
en el país entonces si falta mucho más
por hacer creo que la prioridad número
uno para mí sigue siendo la generación
de empleo número dos fortalecer el
sistema nacional de salud número tres
continúan puntos de vacunación para que
nuestras niñas y niños se vaya a acabar
pronto realizamos las normales data
sobre todas en las clases y número
cuatro la educación de nuestras niñas
niños y una frontal combate a la
corrupción y eso siempre lo voy a
apostar trabajar con transparencia claro
servidor público debe hacerlo siempre
donde esté hacerlo ciencia con
transparencia hablemos del gabinete de
gobierno y de quienes roban a rodear a
la presidenta castro entre ellos hay una
figura importante y es su esposo manuel
zelaya el presidente que fue depuesto en
el año 2009 a través de un golpe de
estado quienes la van a rodear quienes
componen este gabinete
da una buena sensación estas fuerzas que
ya ha reunido para poder gobernar su
opinión diputada figueroa muy puntual
por favor
sí indudablemente ha recogido una gran
cantidad de personas de intelectuales de
personas de alto prestigio en nuestro
país que no dudamos nosotros que van a
hacer lo mejor y verdaderamente nos
parece que el gabinete que ella ha
escogido ha sido muy bien convocado en
base a sus hojas de vida a su capacidad
y lo dudamos nosotros que serán ese
apoyo idóneo y pues la participación de
su propio esposo en el gabinete de
gobierno un hombre que es reconocido
como uno de los mejores políticos en
nuestro país un hombre que tiene un gran
carisma y un gran cariño del pueblo en
el
diputado haber 9 su opinión sobre el
gabinete bueno primero la primera
disolución de las dotará muere que bueno
en realidad creo que solamente el 5 por
ciento de su gabinete muere primera
disolución segundo un gran familia en
desafortunada porque fueron críticos
cuando el presidente anterior tenía a su
hermana como ministra de preside
ministro de estrategia hoy un familión
vea
el secretario privado el hijo cuando
primero hasta el primer tramo secretario
privado el hijo el secretario de defensa
el sobrino jefe de banca jefe de bancada
el partido libre la guía
diputados en el parlacen tren aliado
familias también genera un poco de
desilusión
y no van no es coherente el discurso que
yo plantearon durante toda la campaña
con lo que están haciendo
desafortunadamente lo que con este la
vidente que pareciera que no la va a ser
un postrero de la familia ahora y es
solamente lo lamentable
para el cierre quiero hablar de las
relaciones internacionales esa estrecha
relación que tiene honduras con eeuu una
relación de mucha dependencia de parte
del país centroamericano vayamos a la
vicepresidenta kamala harris allí
presente en tegucigalpa en esta toma de
posesión del mando de la presidenta
castró
mucho interés por parte de washington de
evitar más salidas de caravanas desde el
triángulo del norte y también dispuesto
a hacer muchas inversiones en honduras
guatemala y el salvador para ayudar en
programas sociales y en la estabilidad
institucional esas relaciones
internacionales diputada figueroa no
sólo con estados unidos los países de la
región tiene vecinos complicados nayim
bockel en un lado con un estilo de
gobierno muy particular y en el otro
lado daniel ortega nicaragua también con
un modelo de gobierno muy particular
bueno pues en realidad dijo mucho el
hecho que eeuu enviará a su
vicepresidenta la señora kamala harris a
nuestro país
recordemos que venimos de un tiempo en
el que no hemos tenido embajador de eeuu
en honduras y eso justamente por los
altos índices de corrupción la falta de
credibilidad del gobierno las
vinculaciones que se ha tenido con
narcotráfico eso hizo que alejaran esa
relación verdaderamente tener un
embajador en nuestro país el hecho de
que kamala harris haya venido a nuestro
país dice mucho respecto a la
credibilidad que se tiene de el nuevo
gobierno lo mismo que muchas
representaciones internacionales así que
nosotros creemos también que tenemos
gente talentosa dentro del partido
libertad y refundación con muy buenas
relaciones internacionales que no dudo
yo que será un éxito esas relaciones
internacionales que establezca este
gobierno con los países vecinos
obviamente con situaciones difíciles
como ustedes bien lo mención el salvador
que tiene una peculiaridad forma de
gobernar y obviamente con nicaragua
también que pues digamos no tendrá tan
buena relación con el gobierno de eeuu
sin embargo en este momento eeuu se
muestra como un buen aliado al igual que
muchos otros países que no dudo yo que
van a darle un gran apoyo al nuevo
gobierno
diputada bermúdez sus impresiones en
torno a las relaciones internacionales y
los vecinos y washington
particularmente la básica a mí me tiene
un tanto preocupada porque si usted en
las personalidades que vinieron al al la
toma posesión creo que lo más relevante
fue ahí el príncipe y la la
vicepresidente no está unido kamala
harris luego el resto del país en
realidad mandaron más bien como
representante tercera cuarta y quinta
categoría y la vota también que sí vino
por la representa la vicepresidenta
también de argentina también mujeres
pero más allá de eso primero que me
siento orgullosa como mujer
afrodescendiente que canarias esté en
honduras eso nos da también una gran
apertura para que los nuevos gobiernos
también incluyan la población indígena
afrodescendiente en todos sus temas de
gestión que se les presta atención a
esta población que ha sido
históricamente olvidada sin embargo
también veo que hay un poco de doble
discurso verdad porque durante su
campaña criticaron criticaron el
acercamiento la colaboración la estadía
de esta unidad en honduras con el
gobierno anterior sin embargo ahora sí y
se está viendo como un verdadero
verdadero aliado lo cierto es que no va
a dar un espaldarazo porque también hay
que resolver el tema el triángulo norte
con todo el tema de migración así que
estamos segura con la presencia de
cámara ares la vamos a acompañar
entonces el tema de generación de
oportunidades de empleo para lograr
mitigar y frenar la movilización de las
hermanas y hermanos hondureños hacia
fuera entonces sí creo yo que hay que
revisar un poco ese tema internacional
porque realmente yo lo venía con
muchísima reserva no hubo tanta
representación de otros países de amigos
aliados que yo creían que iban a venir
pero el camal y el príncipe y
la diputada ana bermúdez
a figueroa les agradezco por haber
estado con nosotros aquí en el debate de
france 24 haber puesto en contexto la
realidad y este nuevo capítulo que
comienza a escribir honduras en su
historia política con la llegada al
poder de xiomara castró nueva presidenta
de honduras este país centroamericano
ustedes pueden seguir dejando todos sus
comentarios y preguntas a través de las
redes sociales y sigan viendo france24
[Música]